NFL introduced new uniforms okay for
Thursday's lime-green yeah and people
are saying that you guys have the
ugliest let's take a look what the hell
what do you it looks like you're here
you're doing construction work at night
haha make it look good yeah you make it
you pull it off yeah I think that's
three could pull it off wait a minute
there are four of us sitting here so not
me you're saying do it but the thing is
you know the good thing about that
uniform is we did win and we beat your
LA Rams mm-hmm
I know I know boy that's really I know
quite a mountain to climb
that mean yeah would you high-five each
other after that
you